the jurogan experience one time i was
getting on a plane
and uh a few aisles down from me i saw
george carlin
and
well he yeah he was a few walls ahead of
me and i i you know i'd never met him
before so i didn't want to bother him
and i sat down
and then he he gets up
from his chair and he starts he looks at
me and is walking toward me and i got so
excited i thought
george carlin he wants to talk to me and
he comes over to me and he says
uh
i gotta work on some stuff i'm writing i
gotta read something and then i'm gonna
take a nap so i can talk to you
and he walked it was like basically he
went out of his way to tell me to go
[ __ ] myself
wasn't he just being courteous because
otherwise he would have said i would
talk to you yes yeah but at when it was
getting near the end of the flight when
they announced that they're going to be
descending soon
uh
he came over to me again
and he scribbled his phone number down
on a piece of paper
and he said to me
uh next time you're appearing on tv i
want you to call me and tell me because
i want to see what's going on in that
brain of yours
[Laughter]
and and that was like holy [ __ ] yeah i
only got i saw him perform live a few
times i saw him perform live in new
hampshire when i was like 21 in like
1988
um i saw him there and i saw him at the
comedy store later and i ran into him
once the comment store and he was so
unassuming yes he just walked by said hi
to everybody hello hello like it's like
real friendly easy and just was there to
do his work and
super nice guy and the funny thing is i
had you know george collins number which
and i thought that was like a tremendous
thrill george carlin's a fan i thought
this is unbelievable
i also
met jonathan winters and he gave me his
phone number
and i didn't call either one of them
uh because i i've had those you know
what it's like a couple of celebrities
who've given me their numbers it's like
you know we meet and they're my best
friend the whole world we hit it off
like a lifelong pouch and then you call
them and you go hi it's gilbert oh hello
[Laughter]
it wore off yes
it's kind of to me it's like
when you meet a girl and you get her
phone number
and and she's like oh here's my number
don't lose this don't lose this and
here's here's if i'm not at this number
here's my other number please call me
call me call me all excited
and then you call them up and you go hi
you know i remember we met at uh joe's
party and it's like oh yeah
yeah i think some celebrities just get
exhausted by people wanting things from
them oh i'm sure absolutely
constantly someone thinks that they can
get further up the show business ladder
just by being friends with you being
around you that's why when they act
normal it's uh it's so
refreshing
well it's like when people come up to me
and say
uh could you give me some advice or some
pointers i always feel like underneath
it is like
can you like uh press that button that
makes me a star can you help me yes
give me a lift up yeah yeah but which
doesn't exist yeah no one can do that
it's like i think they they'll look at
you if when you're known and they'll
think oh you know somebody sprinkled
some dust on you magic dust and you
immediately yeah became known and you'll
be able to tell me how i can do that yes
yes where i can get this dust from and
i'll sprinkle on myself yeah well i
think people just looking for shortcuts
all the time right oh yeah yeah and i
think that's also one of the reasons why
celebrities are a little standoffish
with
even when they meet other celebrities
you know i think they just get but then
sometimes they feel like those are the
only people that they know that they can
talk to
like i feel like
uh
who can the cast of friends talk to
right
right
they're all oddly famous yeah in a weird
way
one of the weirdest uh celebrity
encounters i ever had uh was robin
williams
he came to one of my shows
by himself yeah and i didn't know it was
him until a few minutes into talking to
him he had a big crazy beard oh okay and
a baseball hat on and i'm talking that i
was doing like this little meet and
greet after the show and i'm just
talking to this guy yeah and he's like i
really like that bit i really love this
i loved how you did this and that and
then i'm in the middle to talk to him
i'm like holy [ __ ] this is robin
williams oh yeah i didn't realize it
until like a couple minutes into talking
to him i just was talking to him like he
was just a regular guy and he acted like
a regular guy oh yeah i
there were a couple of times at those
clubs he would pop into those clubs all
the time and there were a few times he
called me up on stage with him to riff
with him which was great
and
uh
what i remember most about him i was at
the improv and i wasn't known at the
time i mean i was known to the comics
and
everything like that
and uh and i
i guess he had seen me a few times there
and
uh so i'm getting ready they're just
about to introduce me and then the door
opens up and uh robin comes in so of
course they go
uh
oh oh robin uh you're you're on gilbert
uh go away and robin you're up next
and and robin said to them he goes oh he
goes oh i have a few people in the
audience to see me and i'd like them to
see gilbert first
wow and that always stuck with me that's
so nice of them watch the entire episode
for free only on spotify